As we said at the outset of
this course module, virtualizing the memory subsystem in
a safe and performance conscious manner is the
key to the success of virtualization. What remains
to be vertualized are the CPU and the
devices. That's what we'll talk about next. Memory
virtualization is sort of under the covers. When
it comes to the CPU and the devices,
the interference among the virtual machines living
on top of the hypervisor becomes much
more explicit. The challenge in virtualizing the
CPU and the devices is giving the
illusion to the guest operating systems living
on top, that they own the resources.
Protected and handed to them by the hypervisor, on a need basis. There are two
parts to CPU virtualization, we want to give the
illusion to each guest operating system, that it
owns the CPU, that is; it does not
even know the existence of other guests on top
the same CPU If you think about it,
this is not very far removed from the concerns
of a time shared operating system, which has
to give the illusion to each running process that
that process is the only one running
on the processor. The main difference in the
virtual setting is that this illusion is
being provided by the hypervisor at the granularity
of an entire operating system. That's the first part. The second part is we want
the hyperviser to field events arising due
to the execution of a process that belongs
to a parent guest operating system, in particular during the
execution of a process on the processor. There are going to be
discontinuities that occur. And those program discontinuities, have to be
fielded by the hypoviser, and passed to right guest operating system.